[Música]
o desajuste era palavras que me
simbolizada na infância
seria uma idéia eu tinha bronquite era a
mágoa que um pau e de 15 em 15 dias e
tinha que o hospital tomar injeção causa
da bronquite além disso eu nasci canhoto
ou seja o mundo não faz e quando tava
errada
[Música]
o mais interessante de tudo não tinha
coordenação motora
com 11 anos de idade eu fui na casa do
meu avô tinha um balanço eu mas isso
aconteceu o pessoal até paulo porque o
paulo bater beto na época balançar
é uma coisa genial com 11 anos de idade
então eu como desajustado resolvi fazer
uma coisa e aí eu vi na um panfleto da
escola de cabeça do exército e foi fazer
a prova passei na prova escrita para
fazer a prova física quase morri não
tinha força nenhuma mas ainda assim fui
primeiro acampamento tinha uma crise de
bronquite absurda e eu fui continuando a
academia militar e foi me superando em
torno de paraquedista com muita honra eo
exército então mas essa operação foi
muito fundamental pra mim então o
exército as forças armadas serviu pra
mim como exemplo de superação e eu fazia
questão de que aquelas que estavam
comigo se superasse também ou na parte
intelectual ou na parte física e assim
por diante
então essa é a tônica das forças armadas
e ainda continuo assim depois eu fiz
mestrado doutorado e resolvi então se
professor vem aí voltei pra escola de
cabeça dando aula um amigo meu chegou
assim paulo como é não sair da aula
aí ele fosse rapaz poderia fazer curso
de clown
eu falei o que é isso que vai pagar sua
fé nele é porque é muito ridículo
tentando algo né
bom lá primeiro doutorado duas coisas
aconteceram comigo eu resolvi tentar
fazer alguma coisa pode existir essa é a
minha briga constante ea época que eu
fiz por kanu incrível orientando de
estresse
tá pra algum senão eu sei mas meu caso
de stress e o mais legal do origami é
que ele é uma figura uma coisa
quadradinha muito simples que faz coisas
incríveis ea outra coisa foi fazer um
curso de palhaço
bom na verdade o uso de palhaço é praxe
foi se estressar mais para mim não
foi terrível
qual a questão você se enxerga no
espelho como o seu ridículo todinho e eu
tinha bastante coisa né
então como você já era terrível e estará
então foi o tal negócio difícil é o
curso foi bem pesado você fazer o motor
rio você enxergar muito difícil mas
ainda assim eu fiquei com aquilo na
cabeça
foi horrível curso mas falei que eu acho
que eu quero separar dela
aí joão pessoa cheguei em joão pessoa
passei na fé na um concurso da
universidade estadual da paraíba e
estava lá totalmente estressado de novo
né
e nesse estresse sozinho no mesmo
momento eu fui pra minha médica
homeopata causa de deus
aí ela chegou para mim e falou assim se
gosta de criança faria adoro você não
tem filho não tenha ela ficou com dó de
mim sabe que foi uma coisa triste
e aí ela disse assim você pode falhar
você não trabalha com isso tomar
comentou
a universidade estadual saiu do centro
da cidade foi para um bairro mais
simples e com bastante violência e aí os
adolescentes e universitários ficaram
desesperados com o problema da violência
massa o que vai acontecer com a gente
o que nós vamos fazer aliás essa é a
pergunta que a sociedade tem né
o que nós vamos fazer com a violência
porque uma solução muito simples é o que
você encarcera um pandemónio o
condomínio não é o demônio
então essa possibilidade existe né
mas na verdade ela funciona porque as
coisas que estão venda que estão fora
as escolas também têm cheia de grades
não adianta algumas das coisas que
oferece porque nom enfrentar esse
problema da violência
de alguma forma nós criamos né
é um projeto fantástico na com o nome
maravilhoso chamado tua projeto
universidade em ação
eu arranjei esse tipo fantástico nem a
gente é a gente perceber
[Música]
então o que é mais interessante disso
tudo também é porque eu ia ligar o
palhaço com a diminuição da violência
mas eu não tinha idéia de como fazer
isso
não tinha mesmo não sabia com a gente
demorou
vamos fazer um espetáculo ok 40 minutos
pra escola a esse reunimos e planejarmos
e pensamos e treinamos tá chegou na hora
do espetáculo na escola
o som não funcionou tudo dá errado né
o show não funcionou a gente de palhaço
olhando aquelas crianças oferecem gente
tem que fazer alguma coisa é possível
nada chegou a mim fosse aí
a multidão começou e todo mundo começou
a rir então é descobrir
aí nesse momento que muito mais
importante do que a capacidade do
palhaço está da virtuosidade dele é a
relação que ele queria com as pessoas e
essa relação é fundamental
no fundo no fundo o que eu percebi foi
quem me fez palhaço e quem fez aos
outros nossos amigos palhaços
foi essa relação e essa relação era
simplesmente mágica para que as crianças
ensinavam a gente fazer as coisas bem
aqui e joga água ali é impressionante
isso essa troca mais grave nisso quando
a gente chegou na escola a gente só
ficar olhando isso aí ninguém sabia o
que a gente ia fase e chegar lá o
inspetor lá álbum o vigia fala significa
que vão fazer a gente falou a gente está
olhando
a cena tem pano projeto não temos
trabalhado
ele acha que a gente tá maluco não ia
mesmo mas com o passar do tempo incrível
também porque os nossos palhaços num sal
caracteristicamente exatamente como os
palhaços que a gente conhece muito
tentado de tudo quem a gente achava até
que a gente não era palhaça
ou seja está completamente molhados anos
na mesma escola
depois eu ia me falaram isso olha eu vou
te confessar
quando você chegou aqui eu achei que
você não era palhaço você não servia
para nada mas aí eu descobri que com
pouca coisa tava fazendo uma coisa
porque feliz
então isso é interessante porque a
transformação foi acontecendo ea gente
foi conquistando as pessoas da escola e
essa conquista foi maravilhosa porque os
professores também perceberam que a
disciplina eo ensino não precisa só
sejam rigor na correção ele pode usar o
único porque o último transforma então
os afectos alegres são a arma que nós
temos para tocar no coração das crianças
e não só das crianças como os
professores
a violência é exatamente às vezes
chegava o menino e dá um chute homem
batia e ao invés de revidar eu abraçava
o nosso pessoal para samba o que
aconteceu com esse abraço desarmado a
pessoa
o menino relaxado então um abraço gente
ele desarma violência dessa forma
descoberta fantástica que a gente fez a
gente não votou porque ensaia nada disso
tá bom demais maravilhoso disso é que
foi contaminado toda a comunidade
escolar
nesse sentido foram surgindo então
depois dessa conquista da comunidade
escolar
várias outras coisas
e surge um teatro a gente fez peça na
escola a gente tem um grupo treinando
crianças na sexta série
isso é de teatro levamos de obra levando
um zumbi e vamos testando uma porção de
coisas
em uma dessas coisas que a gente se
aprimorou e também levou a cabo foi o
círculo de console país
bom enfim nesse sentido de construir
mais quando é que ele como é que ele
acontece
ele culpa a gente tá tudo errado tudo
bem diz cuba
enfim aí o que aconteceu o circo é assim
e foi uma retomada das culturas
tradicionais é a ses traz principalmente
da alta dos estados unidos do canadá e
uma pessoa chamada aqui parece que
formulou o que viu isso acontecer então
a gente sempre tem roda com alguma coisa
no centro tipo uma um pano qualquer ea
gente coloca coisas símbolos são
importantes para aquele que errou porque
a gente leva e aí tem o objeto a fala e
este objeto paz é maravilhoso tudo a
gente fosse nossa mas que coisa ridícula
mesmo é simples demais
mas acontece as crianças começam a falar
significa infância é aquele que não fala
certo que será educação tá fazer a
criança falar isso é o que acontece na
escola as crianças não falou com uma
professora e celente chegou para nós se
fosse agora eu conhecia o meu aluno
porque eu ouvir e ouvir as histórias
dele então o afeto tem que contaminará
educação mas a gente sempre ter muito
amor e muito respeito à escola essa
escola escolas em taji uma escola
pequena maravilhosa que ela é uma
característica também fantástica e que
houve uma outra pessoa que não era da
escola a escola
tem uma característica de acolher
aqueles que não são acolhidos por outra
escola
os importantes os especiais
então na verdade foi um amor muito que
surgiu dentro de pessoas que consideram
os seres humanos serem filmados
além disso a gente também trabalhou com
todos os profissionais da escola e aí a
gente descobriu que às vezes os próprios
profissionais da escola não se conhece e
existem 20 vezes tem um monte de
problemas existem pessoas que não gostam
outros gostam mas quando você ouve a
história delas você chora com elas e
você aprende a mala se você se conecta
com elas
o fundo que a gente foi descobrindo é
que a gente foi pegando um mago grande
remoinho grande espiral de amor de
construção e aí eu percebi que eu estava
me tornando especialista em fazer isso e
fazer chorar e eu fiquei na cimpor já
placa negócio lembrou
aí eu preciso falar pra vocês um cara
que para mim é um exemplo incrível fora
tantos outros
esse cara é portanto o trono um palhaço
do movimento palhaço sem fronteira e
criou esse momento ele é o espanhol
catalão ele é dia de surda
quando chega no palco as crianças com
pulando parece que só tem poucas e
quando eu vejo é só pode ser comigo eu
fico feliz sabe como maravilhosa até a
poltrona encontra em 2012
eu falei pô tá pronto na qual é a
ligação do palhaço com o marginal ele
disse total
o palhaço ele é marginal porque
trabalhando não num lugar onde não
existe ele disse
é nesse lugar que existe ainda uma
maneira tão grande que eu fiquei
pensando naquilo nossa incrível bom
subi passou antes tem tudo a ver porque
tem um inconsequente que é seguido por
outros em conseqüência a então aí na
maior sua maior parte desajustados né
então eles acham que o curso de relações
internacionais não deve estar difícil é
igual é o bando de desajustados é isso
aí sabe o que acontece
eu fico feliz por cada um deles
mas na verdade eu tô aqui o motivo do
ataque é para dizer para vocês o
seguinte usando né a sabedoria milenar
japonesa dos orgânicos é um soro
acho que muita gente conhece quando o
japonês fazem chorou e lhe entrega uma
pessoa
ele quer passar a felicidade para essa
então é como se o 10 aquele objeto com
poder um poder transmitir aquilo que eu
desejo
eu queria pegar a sacola de vocês
o coraçãozinho que a gente comeu grupo
fez com carinho para vocês
[Música]
agora ele quer achar como vai dizer que
não foi comprovado for desculpa não cola
enfim restauração aqui disse cíntia quer
dizer o seguinte se você se eu sou
completamente desajustado conseguir
fazer alguma coisa que prestasse se você
joga bola dança faz qualquer coisa
a minha pergunta é advertia dá né
nosso amigo palhaço também dos hospitais
qual a estratégia que o que é o encontro
dos importantes que a magia acontece que
eu queria que vocês fossem contaminados
com essa desde muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]